[Musique]
bonjour chérie
je traite beaucoup ou majoritairement
des dossiers
criminels et correctionnels ça s'appelle
le pénal j'interviens très souvent donc
dans des affaires de viol j'interviens
plusieurs fois dans l'année pour des
affaires de meurtre ou d'assassinat ou
de cou mortel
si je devais définir ce que je fais
comme pénal il y a des expressions
d'avocats et des avocats qui disent du
pénal pénal ou du pénal dur et du pénal
sale parce que voilà c'est du pénal avec
de la plus petite infraction jusqu'au
plus terrible crime et qui concerne
toujours des gens qui sont accusés et
qui sont souvent détenus j'adore ce
genre de pénal moi je suis passionné par
ça c'est pour ça que j'ai fait des
études de droit c'est pour ça que j'ai
passé le barreau c'est pour faire
exactement ça
chaque matin on ne sait pas ce qui va se
passer chaque matin on dépasse il va y
avoir une garde à vue si s'il va falloir
partir en prison parce que parce que je
ne sais pas si il va y avoir une
comparaison médiate et puis la richesse
humaine que Russell cette profession
elle est incommensurable
je défends
des hommes politiques je défends des
inconnus des anonymes je défends des
grands patrons du CAC 40 des chefs
d'entreprise je défends en fait des
personnes qui sont très différentes qui
viennent d'univers extrêmement
différents et je trouve que c'est la
richesse de ce métier quoi c'est que moi
je les rencontre tous
je suis amené à être au contact
d'histoire qui ont avoir avec
l'essentiel peut-être de l'humanité
c'est à dire à la mort la douleur et
l'intégrité corporelle
je ne me sens pas
comme quelqu'un qui peut sauver celui ou
celle que défend mais plus le temps
passe plus je me dis mais c'est une
énorme responsabilité quoi c'est une
énorme responsabilité que de que d'être
la voix de quelqu'un qui est accusé et
qui risque
sa vie ce que je la en parle pas de la
peine de mort mais qui risque sa vie
[Musique]
ce que j'espère être c'est une avocate
la plus libre possible et une avocate de
la défense
je crois que je suis une avocate à la
fois obsessionnelle et
nourri par celles et celui que je
défends et vraiment besoin de je suis
pénis quoi quel que soit l'infraction
[Musique]
je voulais
parler à
[Musique]
ce métier d'avocat il m'arrive par
plusieurs
biens en fait moi ma mère est avocate
donc j'ai été baignée toujours dans ce
monde de la stéril j'ai des souvenirs
très jeunes du Palais de Justice des
tocs les tocs c'est les boîtes aux
lettres d'avocat quand j'étais petite ça
me fascinait que les avocats tous les
avocats chacun leur petite boîte aux
lettres j'ai des souvenirs de la buvette
du palais où ma mère m'a emmenée j'ai
des souvenirs d'elle et de ces associés
de ce qu'elle appelait ses associés qui
étaient des gens qui étaient quand même
très rigolos pour des associés j'avais
une passion pour l'effet divers j'avais
regardé tous les fêtes entrer l'accusé
j'avais lu tous qu'on peut lire sur
l'affaire du petit Grégory j'étais très
passionné par ça et à un moment que je
n'arrivais plus trop à savoir ce que
j'allais faire chez chamara un peu
rattrapé cette histoire d'avocat j'ai
arrêté mes études littéraires et j'ai
recommencé le droit à zéro uniquement
pour faire du droit pénal le métier
d'avocat pénaliste je pense que
il faut en avoir une énorme envie et
j'ai ce souvenir très fort
d'être face à un métier qui me
paraissait peut-être
[Musique]
presque impossible à atteindre pas du
point de vue
social ou intellectuel c'était pas ça
c'était est-ce que psychiquement je suis
capable d'être à cette place là et
cette envie très forte
évidemment elle a grandi quand je suis
devenu avocate et rapidement il y avait
que ça qui me qui m'intéressait qui on
peut dire qu'il m'obsédait j'avais très
envie d'embrasser une carrière
artistique donc j'ai fait énormément de
piano j'ai été au Conservatoire à Nancy
puisque je suis Lorraine et puis ça
s'est arrêté là parce que j'ai je suis
tombée malade j'ai eu une maladie des
mains assez grave et et tout s'est
arrêté et donc j'ai
je me suis dit tout simplement que
j'allais faire le contraire de la
musique j'allais choisir le contraire de
la musique et pour moi le contraire de
la musique c'était le droit ça
m'obligera à ne pas penser et à
continuer à travailler beaucoup
c'est tout ça m'intéressait pas tant que
ça
les matières juridique j'ai pas compris
grand chose
j'ai une révélation et ça ça a été ma
chance c'est que j'ai poussé les portes
du tribunal de Nancy au hasard j'ai vu
un petit bonhomme plaidé je me souviens
plus du tout de qu'elle a faire c'était
mais je me souviens de ce petit bonhomme
qui plaît et qui faisait tout tomber et
puis reprenez ses feuilles les crayons
et je voyais cette salle qui qui le
suivait des yeux qui bougeait avec lui
qui était complètement happé moi aussi
et franchement je me suis dit mais c'est
un c'est un concerto
il est en train de jouer le Concerto
pour violon Brahms mon préféré c'est pas
possible moi j'ai passé
toute mon enfance et mon adolescence ça
ne parlait qu'à travers un instrument
mais ça peut passer par
par
une plaie quand j'ai dit que je voulais
faire du pénal chez moi ça n'a pas été
très bien très bien reçu par
mon père je l'avais plus ma mère donc je
ne sais pas ce qu'elle aurait pensé
peut-être que peut-être qu'elle aurait
trouvé ça bien d'ailleurs mais mon père
a trouvé ça formidable très vite mais au
départ non non il aimait pas ça du tout
quoi c'est-à-dire que pour lui c'était
pas un métier de femme etc donc
je pense que si moi j'ai vécu ça à
l'époque je pense que beaucoup d'autres
femmes l'ont à l'époque c'est quand même
un monde extrêmement masculin il n'y a
quasiment que des hommes il y a quand
même quelques femmes évidemment avocates
qui comptent mais sinon l'immense
majorité des
avocats de pénalistes d'aujourd'hui ont
été formés par des hommes ça c'est ça
c'est vrai moi la première au tout début
dans les cours d'assises il n'y avait
que des hommes
qui n'avaient que des collaboratrices
c'est à dire que il n'y avait que des
hommes de 40 50
qui n'avaient jamais de collaborateur
mais il y avait énormément d'avocats de
pénalistes qui étaient leurs
collaboratrice et qui ne s'installaient
pas après
ou qui n'était pas associé
et donc elles avaient une expérience de
collaboratrice et puis et puis ben elle
passait à autre chose
petit à petit elles se sont installées
petit à petit elles sont devenues
associées et petit à petit elle plaide
de plus en plus devant les cours
d'assises les premières assises c'est
des assises
assez difficiles je rentre dans le
dossier trois semaines avant l'endurance
parce qu'un avocat refuse de défendre
l'accusé évidemment
et pas l'instant d'hésitation je me dis
oui je mets à travailler d'arrache-pied
je rencontre le client il est difficile
c'est un client
un peu un peu mafieux c'est une histoire
de règlement de compte j'ai une peur
bleue
et puis
le process passe
je crois que je serai intervenu ou non
le résultat aurait été le même mais en
tout cas je peux dire que je suis alors
on va dire baptise et je me souviens
très très bien de ma première plaidoirie
d'Asie c'est un truc qu'on ne peut pas
oublier j'étais à l'école d'avocat et
j'étais en stage donc chez Françoise
cotta qui est l'avocate qui m'a formé
depuis le départ j'étais donc à la cour
d'assise de Bobigny à côté d'elle sans
robe puisque les élèves avocats n'ont
pas le droit de porter la robe d'avocat
trois jours de procès ont lieu et d'un
coup la veille du dernier jour
elle m'envoie une cocotte de papier
comme quand on avait quand on était
petit des cocottes de papier
j'ouvre la cocotte j'ouvre un premier je
vois demain j'ouvre une deuxième partie
de la cocotte une flèche j'ouvre la
cocotte en entier il y avait écrit
demain tu plaides
j'ai mon cœur qui s'est arrêté et qui
est tombé dans mes chaussures je sais
même pas j'ai failli défaillir mais
défaillir
et je me suis dit tout de suite ok c'est
terrible mais si tu ne le fais pas là si
tu abandonnes parce que j'ai toujours
impossibilité de se dire non dans la vie
tu pourras plus faire ce métier tu
pourras plus te regarder en face de pas
avoir eu le courage de le faire j'ai
jamais passé une nuit comme ça et voilà
et je l'ai fait alors évidemment c'était
une introduction de 10 minutes sans robe
et mais c'était fou d'avoir réussi à le
faire je me suis jamais dit ça y est je
suis prête je peux être de l'autre côté
je me suis dit je plonge et on verra
bien ce qui se passera c'est extrêmement
égoïste bien sûr pour le client qu'on va
défendre mais en même temps j'avais
vraiment la conviction que il faut
plonger et il faut plonger vite on est
jeune quand on commence
et les magistrats sont impressionnants
on sent qu'on a aucune légitimité donc
souvent on en fait trop et
parfois même un peu dans l'agressivité
parce qu'on a juste
envie d'exister on sait pas très bien
comment quoi c'est difficile d'exister à
la barre enfin l'avocat de la défense va
à l'encontre de l'opinion publique
l'avocat de la défense va à l'encontre
de ce qui apparaît comme une évidence
l'avocat de la défense et du côté du
méchant du mal c'est un métier de lutte
et c'est un métier aussi où on doit en
permanence se situer dans des zones
paradoxales pour trouver les les
arguments de qualité je ne peux pas dire
que ce soit anodin de défendre un ancien
prénom de la République il y a eu une
couverture médiatique peut-être encore
plus importante que certains autres
procès voilà et que donc forcément quand
il y a cette couverture médiatique là
vous êtes même malgré vous portez un peu
plus sur le le devant de la de la scène
mais est-ce que ça a changé quelque
chose dans le regard en revanche
peut-être qu'on m'attendait un peu sur
ce dossier là voilà quand il m'a choisi
dans des circonstances un petit peu
particulières puisque j'étais pas seul
dans le dossier j'étais avec Pierrick et
Pierrick pouvait plus continuer à le
défendre il a choisi de me faire
confiance
en me gardant seul dans ce dossier ça
n'était pas moi qu'il avait qu'il avait
choisi comme avocate au départ et je
trouve que la liberté elle est celle de
l'avocat mais elle est aussi est d'abord
celle du client c'est à dire que je
trouve que un client doit pouvoir à tout
moment changer d'avocat donc je lui
écris mais je sais plus comment j'allais
formuler les choses je crois qu'il a dû
me rappeler je sais pas un quart de
seconde après que ma lettre a été
déposée chez lui pour me dire mais je
comprends pas les questions on continue
tous les deux voilà d'abord ce qui est
intéressant c'est de de rappeler quand
même que c'est pas nous qui choisissons
les affaires sont des gens qui nous
choisissent
je suis institutrice je ne connais pas
l'avocat
les policiers arrivent chez moi à 6h du
matin réveil mes enfants mon mari me
mettre les notes on met le commissariat
je suis accusé de violences sexuelles
sur un de mes élèves
le monde s'écroule si fini ma vie est
terminée la garde à vue elle dure 48
heures pendant 48 heures je me lave pas
je me brosse pas les dents je suis dans
des cellules immondes je pus petit à
petit je pue
je ressens plus à rien
et je suis accusée de la pire des
horreurs
je vois pas mon mari je vois pas mes
enfants
vie et là là la personne qui est avec
moi dans la cellule
me dit mais
prendre l'avocat je te conseille de
l'avocats je te conseille Marie dosée et
puis je te conseille tiens on va prendre
un confrère qui a été qui a été
tellement merveilleux quand il était à
regarder et du coup on m'a dit tu leur
écris chacun une lettre
ils vont venir te voir au parloir et
puis tu verras
et moi l'institutrice je fais ça j'écris
aux deux
et je vois arriver Marie d'oser au
parloir
et je me dis ouais il a travaillé on
sent qu'elle travaille je suis marie
dosée pas lui expliquer que elle va
venir la voir tous les 10 jours que le
dossier enfin d'avoir copié que voilà
comment on va faire voilà ce qui va se
passer que la demande de mise en liberté
etc elle prend du temps elle a l'air
vraiment sérieuse c'est vrai puis après
le lendemain
Eric pour moi est-il arrive
j'ai choisi pour moi tu sais pourquoi
parce que j'ai été broyée en 48 heures
et parce que j'ai besoin d'avoir l'image
d'un avocat qui va broyer ce qui m'a
broyé
et quand on est une femme qu'on pèse 50
kg on ne renvoie pas cette image là
d'un premier abord vous voyez
intuitivement
moi je me suis pertinemment pendant très
longtemps j'ai été l'avocat de la
dernière chance quand tout au tout au
tout début les gars me désignaient en
détention c'était après avoir éclusé les
avocats les plus célèbres avec la grosse
voix qui tapait du point sur la table et
je me suis toujours de celui qui un jour
après deux ou trois ans d'un confrère
célèbre me voit arriver au parloir
moi j'ai pas le droit avec Marie dosée
oui mais c'est moi oh ça va pas
être facile je viens de ça je pense que
c'était
peut-être dans les années 2000 Charles
Pasqua allait comparaître dans trois
dossiers devant la Cour de Justice de la
République
le procès était très proche de ma peine
quelques semaines voire quelques jours
et il y avait trois affaires distinctes
Charles Pasqua découvrait qu'il n'aurait
plus d'avocats dans un de ces dossiers
on était assis je m'en souviens dans un
dans un restaurant et chacun était en
train moi la première d'ailleurs de
chercher quel était le nom de l'avocat
qui pourrait au pied lever intervenir
pour pour remplacer cet avocat qui qui
ne pouvait se maintenir et ce dont je me
souviens très bien c'est que on
cherchait des noms étaient donnés par
les uns par les autres par mois aussi
jusqu'au moment où Charles Pasqua nous a
tous regardé il a tapé un grand coup sur
la taille il dit mais qu'est-ce que
c'est que ça ce sera Jacqueline voilà et
donc
et je dois dire que moi-même je n'avais
pas pensé à moi
et ensuite je l'ai défendu et j'ai
continué à le défendre très très
longtemps mais le concert
sont
confrontés à la médiatisation
de la même manière que les confrères
elle souhaite ou non prendre cette place
là mais
évidemment c'est absolument essentiel
que il y a un traitement
identique des femmes et des hommes qui
font ce métier
[Musique]
effectivement ça fait
bonjour
[Musique]
on y va on fait attention j'ai tout le
monde stop
le plus dur c'est pas forcément ce qu'on
croit l'audience est un moment d'une
intensité extrême d'une adrénaline
extrême mais le plus ça sert de ça c'est
l'avant c'est la préparation d'un
dossier c'est les parloirs 10 fois 20
fois 100 fois sur des gros dossiers pour
essayer de travailler avec un détenu
c'est la gestion des familles des
détenus
je pense que je vais en moyenne au moins
deux trois fois par semaine en prison
mais j'y vais beaucoup ça fait partie du
côté le plus fatigant du métier mais en
même temps le plus important j'ai
totalement un prison tour c'est à dire
que je suis par semaine on va faire
d'abord le lundi matin on va faire mot
le mardi après-midi on fera à Villepinte
et à la santé fleuri Fresnes Nanterre ça
c'est Bois-d'Arcy et dans le 78 donc
c'est quand même bien les avocats c'est
parfois les avoir tous dans la même
prison parce que c'est quand même
beaucoup moins fatigant mais
malheureusement c'est pas nous qui
choisissons où ils sont incarcérés j'ai
besoin d'aller en prison
vraiment j'aurais besoin j'en ai besoin
alors j'en ai besoin pour construire une
défense j'en ai besoin mais j'ai
désormais dans ce monde
envahi par les téléphones envahi par le
bruit la rapidité etc
alors même que j'excède la prison alors
même que je m'y habitue pas j'y vais
deux fois trois fois quatre fois par
semaine je ne m'y habitue pas à chaque
fois que j'ouvre la porte de la prison
je ne suis pas en terrain connu accepté
je m'y habitue pas mais j'ai besoin
de ce rapport au parloir
[Musique]
de ce tête à tête ou plus rien n'existe
que ça en fait
oui bonjour monsieur c'est pour le
palourd avocat
merci
c'est toujours difficile à présent la
prison c'est quand même un lieu
extrêmement extrêmement dur je me sens
pas bien en assez lourde de portes qui
se fait
c'est assez sinistre c'est assez
angoissant
donc ce sont des lieux dans lesquels on
va on est content d'y aller parce qu'on
y exerce notre métier on va rencontrer
on est quand même un peu un lien entre
entre l'extérieur et les personnes qui
sont enfermées
mais c'est toujours un lieu dans lequel
je vais avec un peu de difficulté
il y a des clients que je rencontre
évidemment pour la première fois au
parloir et du coup je les rencontre pour
la première fois au parloir entre quatre
murs et moi j'adore ce moment que c'est
le moment le plus un des moments les
plus géniaux de notre profession cette
première rencontre où on va voir ou pas
si on va bien si ça match parce que faut
que ça match en fait faut qu'il y ait de
la confiance j'ai les visages des
personnes avec qui c'est très mal parti
enfin le commencement a été très dur le
premier rendez-vous a été violemment je
me souviens encore rien qu'un jour il
est sorti j'ai entendu dire
dans la salle d'attente je m'en suis
pris plein la gueule et je ne savais pas
s'il allait dire oui ou non mais j'ai
posé mes conditions non monsieur
attendez vous commencez pas comme ça
déjà vous commencez pas comme ça
d'accord vous passerez pas en force et
on passera pas en force on passe jamais
en force devant un tribunal sauf que le
travail de l'avocat et ça c'est quelque
chose que les je pense les gens savent
feu mais l'avocat c'est pas un perroquet
d'un client qui vous dit des choses
absurdes je pense que le client me dit
j'essaye avec le plus d'énergie possible
de le remettre dans l'axe de la les
éléments objectifs à charge contre lui
c'est que je ne caresse pas dans le sens
du poil en disant comme vous avez raison
de dire que cette fille est une petite
menteuse et je lui dis attention il y a
de l'ADN dans la culotte attention il y
a le témoignage de Madame machin il y a
des dossiers ou un prévenu ou un accusé
ne peut pas être innocent parce que le
dossier quand on lit on sait qu'il n'est
pas innocent c'est impossible et que du
coup notre travail ça va être de
d'arriver avec lui d'avancer et
peut-être de le faire accoucher d'une
vérité et de l'amener lui à la
reconnaissance je viens d'en faire
l'expérience difficile dans un procès
récent c'était une affaire je défendais
un jeune homme chilien
accusé d'avoir assassiné son
ancienne petite amie japonaise qui était
venue faire ses études
à Besançon ce qui a été le plus
difficile dans dans ce dossier là c'est
c'était la
c'était la façon de pouvoir défendre un
homme qui que tout accablé
et
qui restait dans dans une position que
je trouvais
difficile à soutenir et en même temps
cette position là elle te elle était
réaffirmée réaffirmé depuis deux ans
réaffirmer au cours du procès quand tu
avocat tu cette espèce de résistance là
elle t'impressionne tu te dis mais et
finalement si finalement cette
résistance là c'est pas aussi parce que
il y a peut-être quelque chose c'est
difficile d'abandonner complètement le
doute mais ce que j'ai trouvé le plus le
plus compliqué et lourd dans ce dans ce
dossier c'est d'avoir envie de défendre
du mieux que je pouvais
sans le trahir c'est leur intérêt à eux
d'avouer le crime parce que les charges
sont tellement accablantes que la
dénégation va rajouter la couche d'ex
génération qui va aggraver la peine ou
qui va rendre les juges et les jurés
complètement fermés aux arguments de
défense une avocate la plus libre
possible c'est aussi celle qui doit
pouvoir
rester libre autant qu'il est possible
de son système de défense ça n'est pas
toujours simple c'est à dire d'essayer
de rester maître de cette défense et de
ne pas se la laisser imposer par son
client d'abord et puis oui rester libre
vis-à-vis de tout des magistrats des
pouvoirs des pressions quelconque de
l'envie de plaire aux médias de
privilégier d'abord ce que l'on pense
parfois on se fonctionnement mais ce que
l'on pense être la meilleure défense
possible construire une plaidoirie c'est
d'abord noter au fur et à mesure de
l'audience
tout ce qui paraît avoir été
marquant je suis très j'essaye d'être
très attent à l'audience et de voir tout
ce qui se déroule comme une éponge et de
me mettre à la place si on a la cour
d'assise de juré pour essayer de
ressentir ce que eux ont ressenti et
essayer dans l'app plaidoirie de pas
être à côté quoi c'est à dire que si je
parle uniquement d'un dossier papier
alors que pendant une semaine il y a un
milliard de petites choses ou de grandes
choses qui sont passées dans une
audience je serai à côté dans ma
plaidoirie ça peut être des paroles ça
peut être un retard ça peut être
un orage ça peut être des propos qui
sidèrent ça peut être des larmes ça peut
être un rire bref c'est une attention
très grande à tout ce qui rentre dans la
cour d'assises
et ensuite ça va être de se distancier
de tout ça et la nuit avant de plaider
d'essayer de chercher en soi
tous les messages que nous envoie notre
inconscient donc la plaidoirie moi je
l'écris avant de m'endormir pendant une
ou deux et ensuite je mets mon réveil un
peu tôt le matin et là je prends comme
si c'était des cadeaux envoyés de je ne
sais quel ciel
les idées que mon cerveau a fabriqué la
nuit et ça ce sont les bonnes idées j'ai
besoin de trouver une idée ou une image
un fil conducteur qui va me permettre
après de débrayer et cette image ou
cette idée elle doit être un peu
elle doit être originale enfin en tout
cas elle doit choper mon auditoire pour
leur dire ah oui c'est vrai que ce
détenu là il a eu cette attitude à un
moment ou cette voilà ou une idée c'est
comporté comme ça parce qu'il vient de
là en fait il y a un fil conducteur qui
va me permettre de tirer tout le long de
ma plaidoirie et après de dérouler je me
rappelle que je commençais par il était
une fois
et je reprenais en disant non
non non il était pas une fois
c'était pas un compte
mais voici l'histoire de introduire
l'idée du conte c'est proposer aux jurés
au juge
de retrouver
de leur enfance parce que leur enfance
elle est vraiment importante pour
comprendre les histoires criminelles et
puis ensuite mon distancié en leur
disant non c'était pas il était une fois
attention c'est une vraie histoire le
travail de plaidoirie chez moi est
toujours passé par l'écriture toujours
parce que ça me rassure parce que j'en
ai besoin parce que j'ai besoin de cette
bouée de sauvetage si il y a naufrage et
en même temps je ne le je ne la lis pas
c'est un travail
c'est ce que je dis va être compris reçu
utile
le grand art c'est rare c'est d'arriver
à faire rire ou sourire et si on y
arrive et que c'est pas indécent alors
je crois qu'on a gagné énormément
dans
le fait d'avoir amené à soi les jurés et
les juges
on n'y arrive pas toujours l'idéal de
plaidoirie je sais pas si j'y arrive
c'est une plaidoirie ou on oublie que
j'existe et on ne voit que la personne
pour laquelle je parle le détenu dans le
box si les juges et les jurés sont
collés à la réalité de l'instant
criminel si l'instant criminel ne
provoque chez eux que du dégoût de la
colère
ou un besoin de vengeance alors on
risque pas d'atteindre notre but
convaincre ce n'est pas clair parfois
même convaincre ses déplaire je sais je
sais que vous allez
trouver ce que je vais dire
insupportable il m'arrive de dire ça
magistrat
mais je suis pas là pour leur plaire je
suis là à un moment donné pour dire ce
qu'ils ne veulent pas entendre
pour dire ce qui est insupportable pour
dire ce qu'ils ne vont pas supporter
je ne veux pas avoir le mot qui blesse
je ne veux pas avoir un mot qui se
répète et je ne veux pas avoir
l'horrible gaffe je pense qu'on doit à
nos clients d'avoir un texte de
plaidoirie qui soit absolument contrôlée
moi j'ai toujours eu peur de ça j'ai
toujours eu peur
de faire payer à celui que je défends ce
que j'avais dit et ça
je l'ai déjà non pas vécu mais
je l'ai déjà vu
j'ai déjà vu des confrères ou je me
disais mais c'est pas possible là
il est en train de se mettre le tribunal
ado mais c'est pas c'est pas lui qui se
mettrait dans la dose
c'est celui qui est derrière qui va
prendre quelques fois sur le bord des
parties civils et bien j'enrage j'enrage
que j'enrage quand la cuisine n'est pas
parfaitement défendue c'est quelque
chose que je trouve insupportable comme
déséquilibre quand l'accusation est
forte et que la défense est
médiocrinable c'est pas fréquent enfin
bon ça arrive évidemment comme dans
toute situation humaine
je suis révolté je suis très révolté et
quelquefois genre je suis allé à la
limite d'aller
ça m'est arrivé d'aller donner des
arguments à la défense discrètement
tellement
[Musique]
je suis révolté par un procès dans
lequel il y a un déséquilibre quand j'ai
terminé si je me souviens de ce que j'ai
plaidé parce que très souvent je me
souviens pas de ce que j'ai plaidé
et je demande à celle où celui qui
m'accompagne quand je suis pas toute
seule est-ce que je dis ça est-ce que
j'ai dit ça je l'ai dit ça je l'ai dit
ça parce que je ne m'en souviens plus je
suis incapable de me souvenir de ce que
j'ai dit et donc j'ai toujours peur
d'avoir oublié beaucoup de choses mais
en tout cas quand je m'en souviens
je suis nécessairement frustrée puisque
je me souviens de ne pas avoir dit tout
ce que j'ai écrit quand je sors d'une
plaidoirie je pense trois fois sur
quatre que c'était un naufrage
je n'ai jamais jamais été
contente de
[Musique]
d'une plaie mais moi la Nuit d'Après je
me refais toujours la petite Marie
idéale et parfaite que j'aurais dû faire
quoi je pense toujours à la chose que
j'ai oublié je pense toujours à la forme
oui je pense toujours à ça parce que en
fait ça n'est jamais assez bien quoi une
Cédric quand vous défendez quelqu'un
quand quelqu'un vous donne cette
charge-là cette mission là
moi en tout cas je ne trouve jamais ça
assez bien il y a des plaidoiries
laquelle je pense j'ai oublié j'ai raté
j'ai complètement raté la chute je crois
que c'était il y a 7 ans je pense qu'il
y a pas une journée
une journée sans que je
j'y pense et repense j'ai beau me
résonner en me disant mais c'est pas ça
qui a fait que c'est pas parce que tu as
pas terminé comme comme tu devais
terminer et que
celui que tu as défendu a pris deux ans
ou trois ans de plus je le sais mais je
ne supporte pas cette idée
je n'accepte pas d'avoir
d'avoir écorché cette chute
[Musique]
vous m'avez appelé dites-moi
exactement c'est ce que je leur ai
expliqué hier le dossier va être envoyé
au commissariat de leur domicile et du
coup après je prendrai contact avec le
commissariat et on organisera le fait
qu'il se présente
je vous tiens au courant quand je les ai
eu la semaine prochaine à très vite à
bientôt au revoir au revoir
[Musique]
je crois qu'il y a un moment que Jeanne
que j'aime le plus dans ce métier c'est
le moment de la fin de la plaidoirie
quand vous croisez le regard de votre
détenu et que l'émotion dans ses yeux
vous lisez dans ses yeux un merci
d'avoir bien parlé pour lui et moi
j'aimerais que ça soit ça mon style
la féminisation de la profession et la
féminisation des avocats dans les cour
d'assises ont amené probablement des
postures
plus discrètes des voix qui portent
peut-être un peu moins et ont amené une
autre façon d'être il y a 20 ans et
c'était merveilleux j'adorais ça moi je
me souviens encore de certains confrères
et plein il plaide attends j'y vais j'y
vais et c'est vrai que c'était beau il y
avait des citations c'était drôle
nous on n'a pas on n'a pas joué sur ce
registre là nous empruntons peut-être
des chemins un peu un peu différents je
pense que parfois il y a
il y a cette petite approche peut-être
plus
discrète plus
fine
mais peut-être qu'on a aussi des choses
en moins mais en tout cas des moyens
différents pour parvenir à un même but
c'est vrai que ce qu'on appelait les
effets de manche c'est à dire l'avocat
qui s'agite et qui crie existe beaucoup
moins on est arrivé à mon humble avis en
connaissant nos dossiers par coeur
c'était pas toujours le cas
il y avait moins d'effets de manche mais
je pense que il y avait plus de
précisions
il y avait plus d'émotions contenu aussi
c'était moins tonitruant
c'était moins spectaculaire
mais
on a su capter l'attention il ne faut
pas que l'avocat de pénaliste est limite
l'avocat pénaliste
il faut pas que la femme avocate quand
elle plaide limite
qui ont longtemps été
celles de nos confrères les femmes
pénalisées mais du coup à contrario on a
peut-être du coup plus d'imagination
plus d'inventivité plus de prise de
risque parce que nous on nous a jamais
on va pas faire de ces effets de manche
qu'on a vu et puis on a pas envie je
crois et que finalement peut-être que ça
amène de la nouveauté et que ça nous
fait prendre enfin moi sur les femmes
que j'admire et les femmes avocates que
j'admire il y en a plein il y a toujours
cette imagination cette il y a jamais
une qui plaide de la même façon que
l'autre je pense que les plaidoiries ont
changé et je pense même que les
magistrats si aujourd'hui
il n'avait plus en face de que ses
confrères qui plaidaient comme une
plaidait il y a 20 ans
il ne le supporterait pas je dirais
qu'on est un peu plus libre moi je le
ressens comme ça sur ce métier qui est
assez quand même historiquement masculin
le fait d'être une femme une fois qu'on
a passé les difficultés que ça peut être
parce que oui les femmes gagnent moins
d'argent je pense que les hommes il y a
plus mais une fois qu'on a passé ça il y
a plus de liberté j'en suis sûr on a
tendance à penser qu'aux assises le
moment le plus stressant c'est la
plaidoirie évidemment c'est extrêmement
anxiogène même quand on la prépare
parfois quand on plaide ou juste avant
mais en fait il y a un moment qui est
peut-être le plus angoissant c'est celui
de l'attente du délibéré c'est quand
votre téléphone portable sonne et que
c'est la greffière et qu'elle vous dit
mettre c'est pour dans une heure et là
c'est le moment où l'angoisse est la
plus totale puis une heure après on va
dans cette salle d'audience c'est
d'ailleurs les moments sont de plus en
plus crescendo plus on va dans les
salles d'audience et il y a quelque
chose qui est très marquant quand on
rentre dans cette salle d'audience qu'on
attend la cour qu'on ne sait pas encore
le délibérer c'est le silence j'ai
jamais si on peut entendre un silence je
n'ai jamais entendu un silence de cette
profondeur là plus personne ne parle
l'accusé dans son box et on attend
chacun la tête dans ses pensées de
savoir ce que la Cour va décider
ces instants là en fait ces instants
tout bascule et notamment quand on
pleine d'aquittement ces instants tout
bascule ou je sais toujours pas s'il
faut que je regarde et je réussis je les
regarde pas évidemment je les regarde
pas comme d'habitude je me lève je me
mets le plus le plus près de la cuisine
en me disant de toute façon là c'est
c'est à nous deux que ça va arriver et
quelque part ma place elle est vraiment
là ne les regarde pas il y a pas il y a
pas de signaux ça c'est les débiles
c'est terrible au moment de la décision
on regarde les jurés on est quand ils
rentrent on essaye toujours d'analyser
il y avait un peu de mythologie de dire
si il nous regarde nous avocat de la
défense s'ils arrivent à soutenir notre
regard ça veut dire qu'ils nous ont
suivi j'y croyais vraiment en fait on se
rend compte que j'ai eu des jurés qui
baissaient la tête et qui finalement
avaient des bonnes décisions parce que
même pour eux le moment est tellement
fort que voilà ils ont aussi du mal à
lever la tête c'est très très douloureux
et très souvent aussi j'ai attendu des
libéré dans les cellules
vous me souviens même ça a pu durer cinq
heures six heures je me souviens de
cette accusé qui s'était endormie je me
souviens de je me souviens d'avoir joué
aux cartes
moi je pense que ça c'est très important
pour un avocat attendre de libérer le
bruit
le bruit ça y est c'est vraiment ça
il y a une portail et c'est bon
et puis en fait c'est pas ça
il faut vivre ça pour savoir ce qu'ils
vivent c'est un livre qui a été publié
en 1994 et c'est le livre des époux
viements des parents du petit Grégory il
décrypte toute l'histoire
on s'expliquant et il y a notamment un
moment que je trouve absolument
magnifique sur ce qu'un accusé pour
ressentir en attendant un délibéré parce
que le père de Grégory Jean-Marie
Villemin a été accusé lui du meurtre de
Bernard Laroche et il a donc été un
accusé devant la Cour d'Assise et décrit
au début l'attente de se délibérer et le
moment où on lui rend ce verdict ce
livre il est fait en dialogue du coup
c'est Jean-Marie et Christine qui
dialogue par écrit donc Jean-Marie il a
fallu se mettre debout
j'ai cru que tu allais tomber je t'ai
dit pense à Grégory pas à moi moi c'est
ce que j'ai fait en marchant jusqu'au
box
Christine donc elle qui parle les jurés
sont revenus chez aperçu la femme la
plus âgée d'entre eux qui nous
regardaient toujours avec gentillesse
elle était défigurée elle me regardait
les larmes aux yeux je me suis dit il
est condamné
la sentence est tombée après quelques
secondes mais pour moi cela durait une
éternité entre chaque question coupable
oui
préméditation oui les veines de mon coup
de battait toute la salle devait
entendre battre mon cœur
circonstances atténuantes oui
là j'ai respirer très fort et puis le
verdict cinq ans d'emprisonnement dont
un an avec sursis
il y a eu un silence de mort pas un
bruit des gens pleurer je me suis
approchée de toi comme une somme non
bulle
ça décrit pas mal ces moments et c'est
vécu par des gens qui l'ont vécu c'est
encore mieux que des mots d'avocats
et parfois
on a laissé aucune trace dans des
libérer d'un tribunal d'une juridiction
enfin il faut avoir cette humilité de de
s'en rendre compte parfois nous n'avons
pas existé ils ont décidé sans nous
parfois on a eu aucune influence c'est
très dur c'est très dur de le supporter
mais c'est vrai le mauvais résultat
enfin ce qu'on appelle oui un mauvais on
parle comme ça nous de résultats c'est
peut-être un peu trivial mais c'est de
dire en fait une peine qu'on considère
nous qui n'a pas été juste et qui
probablement n'a pas été ne va pas être
comprise par un accusé ou n'est pas du
tout la bonne à la lecture nous qu'on
avait du dossier c'est un sentiment de
de solitude absolue de responsabilité on
se sent tellement coupable enfin moi je
me sens tellement coupable qu'est-ce que
j'ai loupé qu'est-ce que j'aurais dû
faire est-ce que j'aurais dû poser cette
question là est-ce que j'ai oublié des
choses dans ma plaidoirie on se sent
profondément responsables et
profondément seul c'est des moments très
durs surtout avec l'énergie qu'on a mise
dans des assises c'est une énergie ça
dure de 9 heures du matin à 20h 21h le
soir on ne fait que ça le téléphone on
peut plus répondre les soirées on peut
plus y aller enfin c'est une bulle dans
lequel on est totalement enfermé dans
lequel on se démène pour être la parole
d'un homme qui d'une femme qui elle va
être peut être vide broyée par un
système donc on s'est tellement donné
comment on n'a pas réussi c'est une
terrible violence même pour un avocat je
pense qu'on ne peut pas faire ce métier
d'avocat de la liste sans avoir
une aide psychologique ou psychiatrique
je sais que ces techniques là elles sont
très importantes pour
garder
ce qu'on est de la manière la plus
la plus efficace pour notre client c'est
à dire ne pas être
dévasté par une colère une peur un
stress il est arrivé
que je me suis submergé
et notamment
soit au cours d'audition d'interrogation
ou d'un stand audience ou
la vague émotionnelle
et très très forte et où elle monte en
moi
voilà il ne m'est jamais arrivé de
craquer mais il m'est arrivé de pleurer
oui de pleurer je pense qu'on l'a pas vu
j'ai toujours fait en sorte qu'on ne le
voit pas en tout cas celui ou celle que
je défendais de la évidemment pas eu
et j'espère que non plus mais ça m'est
déjà arrivé
mais parce que parce que ça arrive à un
moment où on s'y attend pas parce que
cette phrase elle résonne sur d'autres
affaires
et puis parce que tout simplement parce
que tout simplement
celles et ceux qu'on défend
sont parfois bouleversants c'est tout
voilà
ces affaires là tu atteint ça atteint
parce que parce que tu es dans la
souffrance de part et d'autre et dans
cette espèce de Ben dans la souffrance
du matin jusqu'au soir tu as des
témoignages qui sont insupportables de
douleurs tu as tu as des vies brisés de
part et d'autre donc oui à moins d'être
totalement insensible et même si on a la
robe et qu'on essaie de lutter oui
évidemment que ça ça atteint et puis en
même temps tu as quelqu'un
que tu es cette défendre et pour lequel
tu essaie de garder une toute petite
fenêtre ouverte donc
l'enjeu il est il est il est énorme et
et tu le portes et quand tu sors de d'un
procès comme ça tu sors
il faut quelques jours pour revenir ici
sur terre et revoir la lumière
[Musique]
l'île de Ouessant a une importance
majeure dans ma vie et dans ma vie
d'avocat
j'imagine pas avoir une très grosse
audience sans être venue au préalable
quelques jours avant si possible
trouver
énergie
concentration calme
et confiance un peu
pour affronter
plusieurs jours de procès oui c'est vrai
que je viens quasiment systématiquement
pour me préparer à des procès que je
trouve une lourdeur particulière quand
on est dans dans ces longs procès par
exemple
on est d'abord
immergé dedans quoi c'est à dire que ne
serait-ce que par le temps qu'on y passe
forcément ce sont des des métiers des
affaires
plus précisément dont on parle
et avec lesquels on a cet échange et
donc ça s'invite dans votre vie on ne
ferme jamais la porte de nos affaires
quoi c'est à dire que vous rentrez le
soir chez vous peut-être plus que dans
d'autres métiers vous ne fermez pas la
porte quoi donc si vous voulez la
cloison entre entre ce que vous vivez et
votre vie
elle n'existe pas tant que ça quoi
quelque chose d'obsédant mais c'est pas
ça ne fait pas du mal ça ne ça ne gâche
rien ça gage pas mon quotidien ça gâche
pas mon amour du cinéma ça gâche pas mon
histoire d'amour mais c'est tout le
temps là tout le temps
[Musique]
il se protège évidemment d'abord en
étant dans des relations de confiance
avec les gens qu'on aime et puis au-delà
de l'affection des gens il y a le fait
de pouvoir être au contact de choses
belles la nature la mère le soleil
levant l'herbe les odeurs d'agent les
choses belles c'est aussi il y a de les
livres et le cinéma
s'entourer le plus possible d'affection
et de beauté et c'est vraiment très
important l'énergie qu'on doit apporter
aux clients elle trouve quand même sa
source dans le fait de connaître le
bonheur
ce contact quotidien avec la mort ou
l'idée de la mort des autres doit amener
de ma part une fréquentation de ce qui
est vivant de ce qui est très vivant je
pense que c'est aussi une des chances de
mon métier que de me faire mesurer
tous les jours tous les soirs ce que
vaut la vie la vie vaut beaucoup
[Musique]
quand je nage entre
l'Atlantique et la Manche parce que
ouessante se rencontre l'Atlantique et
la Manche
je viens laisser dans la mer
des mots qui m'ont blessé je viens
laisser dans la mer la
douleur de ce que j'ai entendu je viens
laisser dans la mer le stress du verdict
qui tombe et puis je viens aussi
chercher
le mot qui m'apparaît fort pour le
prochain procès
quand on est dans
cette action là dans le procès dans la
défense voilà on laisse un peu
on laisse un peu derrière
tout ce qui est votre vie quoi tout ce
qui est vos éventuels fragilités
les moments éventuellement difficiles
que que vous traversez ça prend la
première place quoi défendre quelqu'un
en fait c'est incroyable on a cette
relation privilégiée avec un prévenu ou
un accusé on a une voix que personne n'a
on a ses heures de parloir on a ces
choses que personne n'a
le concernant ce n'est pas un métier
difficile du tout parce que
je suis vraiment à ma place donc j'ai
aucun mérite vraiment
je suis vraiment à l'endroit
où je devais être avant d'être difficile
c'est quand même un métier incroyable
quoi c'est pour moi vraiment des plus
beaux métiers du monde je suis
heureux dans ma profession mais vraiment
émotionnellement psychologiquement
intellectuellement mais c'est une
riche c'est une chance inouïe exercice
en fait c'est notre métier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allô
[Musique]